[Music]
[Applause]
so
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage
dave ramsey
wow
[Applause]
thanks guys thanks guys
well welcome to reset 2021.
how many of us want to do over after
last year
oh man we really need a reset
all of us do in so many areas of our
life and
thank you guys for joining us online
there's some 250
000 or so have signed up to join us
tonight online thank you for you guys
being here
at life church right here in oklahoma
city thank you to pastor craig and amy
for
having us and the staff here absolutely
incredible
you're in for an incredible night this
is going to be a lot of fun
and we need it we need
a reset we need a restart
we need this white board we need this
new year experience
all of us do i do personally and i'll
tell you somebody else that did
you might remember a story
about a famous mother pig
she had three famous sons
they were known as the three little pigs
and one day mother pig looked up and
said
you can no longer live in my basement
and play video games
you must go out into the world and make
your way
and she encouraged her young sons to
make their way in the big bad world and
as she did she said beware
of the big bad wolf he's ravenous
and he will be patrolling the streets
looking for dumb little pigs
so the three little pigs packed their
bags and said goodbye to their mother
and each went
off on a different path well the first
little pig
we know about this little pig we've all
heard about him all our lives
he's yolo pig
you only live once life's short
so let's get straight to it thank god
it's friday
oh god it's monday and so he didn't want
to invest a lot of time or trouble
into his abode and so instead of
spending time
preparing for his future the first guy
he ran into was some straw sold him some
straw and he built a
straw house the next little pig
we call him ish pig
because he did everything ish
ish pig he sort of did things
and so he a little more than a straw
house he wanted to invest a little more
time
and a little more trouble into his
future and he knew he should do these
things but
it was a lot of trouble and he would do
it ish
and as we all know ish is a wish and he
um
ran into a guy with some twigs and he
built his twig out twig house
he knew he should invest himself in his
future but when all his broke little
piggy friends told him it was normal to
go into debt to buy a new truck and go
to a fancy school and live in a
neighborhood he couldn't afford he
listened to them
[Music]
the third pig mr brickhouse
i'm going to live like no one else so
that later i can live and
give like no one else there's a big bad
wolf out there and
he invested effort and time and
discipline and trouble into all aspects
of his life and he
built the brick house and any good child
knows what happens next
the big bad wolf named pandemic came
along
he's named 2008 with a real estate
bubble
he's named 911 with the towers
being attacked he's named tornado
he's named hurricane the big bad wolf is
named forest fires
and he came looking for little pigs to
devour
and he came to yolo pig's house and he
said come out come out and the first
little pig said i've heard about you my
mom told you
i'm not coming out you just want a pork
sandwich
not a chance not by the hair of my
chinny chin chin
and the wolf said but i'll huff and i'll
puff and i'll blow your house down
and he did
and he shut down schools and businesses
he shut down an entire economy
and the little pig escaped barely and
ran to his brother's house
with the twigs and the big bad wolf
came to the twig house and ish pig was
there and
he said come out come out and he said oh
no not by the hair of my chinny chin
chin he said but i'll huff and i'll puff
and i'll
take your life away
and he said no and he huffed and he
puffed and he blew his house down and
the two little pigs ran for their
brother's house
they ran to the brick house and he
huffed and he puffed
and he huffed and he puffed and he was
unable to blow the house down
and so he left and he went looking for
more
yolo and-ish pigs
because the third pig
had defeated the wolf
the wolf's coming he's real
it's called life stuff happens
and we have to be ready we got to be the
third pig
and some of us have learned that a long
time ago because we got our house blown
down
earlier and so this time when it came
around we were ready
but this time when it came around some
others it's uh
you know it's more of your wake-up call
this time this is your time when you say
well
next time he comes i'll be
i'll be there where i need to be
sometimes the big bad wolf came like he
did this last year in 2020 and people
had no money
they had no savings they were in debt
they were up to their eyeballs in debt
they needed to get out
they may have lost their jobs it's been
a really hard time
for a lot of folks the big bad wolf is
real
but what we want to do is we want to
reset
and say never again
we're going to be ready never again
we're going to be ready because see when
everything's going good
you can do stupid and get away with it
but as warren buffett says when the tide
goes out you can tell who is skinny
dipping
so you can still be the third pig you
can still get ready
i learned all this the hard way myself
by going broke
it was in my 20s and the big bad wolf
came along in the form of the bank
getting sold to another bank and
they blew our house down and it took two
and a half years to lose everything we
owned and
we were so scared we couldn't breathe i
had brand new babies and
a toddler and a marriage hanging on by a
thread and i didn't know what to do and
i started learning god's ways of
handling money
started applying them to our lives we
started building
a brick house
a house that works when times are good
and a house that works when times are
bad we started building a financial life
that works when times are good and when
times
are bad and so this year
i was in a different position personally
and
a lot of people who followed those same
principles were in a different position
when the big bad wolf came and he huffed
and he puffed and his
house didn't fall down you can learn
to be the third pig
it's a learned skill and that's what
we're doing tonight
you can be in control of your financial
situation
you can build this brick by brick you
could go to ramsey plus and take a free
trial that's a brick
you could pack your lunch instead of
going through the drive-through
that's nine dollars that's a brick you
could sell the old couch that's in the
garage to somebody
put the cash towards your emergency fund
that's a brick
you could cut up your credit card and
close it and pay it off that's two
bricks
you could pay off another credit card
and cut it up that's two more bricks
you could even someday have a whole
bunch of bricks and pay off your
mortgage
i mean you can put yourself in a
position where when this stuff comes at
you
you're in a different place
you've changed your family tree there's
not a single magic
brick and there's not a single magic
pill
this is a change in the way we view our
lives
and what we value are we going to be
yolo
are we going to be ish or are we gonna
win and tonight's the night we learn to
reset
so you're gonna hear us talk a lot about
ramsay plus and we want to come
alongside you daily
in ramsey plus we want to come alongside
you weekly over the next 90 days and
show you exactly what to do
to begin to build your brick house to
begin to put a life in place
that is not as vulnerable and
takes advantage of good times as well
this year can be different regardless of
what wolves are out there
i don't know what 2021's gonna hold it
already has started weird
but i'm getting old and i've seen a lot
of these storms
and i've watched the last half of my
life of them
from a brick house the first half of my
life i spent getting blown around
because i wasn't ready and it's a
different world
when you get yourself and your family
ready and that's what we want for you
we want you to have hope we want you to
win
we want you to look at your kids and
know that they have a future
because of the actions you took we want
you to look and be able to reach across
the aisle and help somebody who's
struggling
because of the actions you took and the
position you put yourselves in
so before you can build a house you got
to lay a foundation
foundations are really important
foundations are all about the choices
that you make the behaviors and the
values that you hold who
are you why do you handle money
the way that you do rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author two times and
probably now three had a new book come
out this week called
know yourself know your money
and she's gonna help us lay a foundation
because when you know yourself you know
how to handle your money
and you're in a better position to do
the stuff that we're going to talk about
all through the night she's a
world-class communicator she spent the
this week doing 160 media appearances
all over the place including good
morning america to launch this book
and i'm really proud to say she's my
daughter so
welcome rachel cruz
thank you
well after 10 years of traveling the
country
speaking about this topic doing podcasts
writing books
i have realized that money yes money is
very tactical
but money is also extremely emotional
and so i'll hear people say well if i
can just make this much a year
i'll be okay or if i just had this much
in savings
all my problems would go away and
the truth is when that's where your hope
lies day in and day out and that emotion
the finish line always moves
if you think back beginning of april
like april 4th
ish random day but think okay so
everything kind of
hit the fan mid-march you know stuff
started shutting down
in a end of march so we were probably in
this for about three weeks
and i will never forget going to bed one
night and i just had
this fear come over me and we were
laying in bed and i told winston my
husband i was like gosh babe i just
i'm just fearful i really am i don't
know why but
but what if we never go back to normal
what what if this
is normal what if financially
we never recover what if like our 401k
just bottoms out what if we really can't
get toilet paper
that was a real thing right what if
there is a meat shortage
what if amazon prime really doesn't
deliver in two days anymore
what are we gonna do and i remember he
looked at me and he was like rachel
we're good we're okay and what he was
saying
in his head in his logic was we were the
third pick i mean winston and i've been
married
11 years and we've been doing this from
day one of marriage
so again tactically we're that third pig
we have been budgeting we have been
saving we are out of debt
we have been generous we have been doing
it all but i still
had this fear and then the next night it
was the same conversation
and it was frustrating because my
emotions were not matching my reality
but i remember what dr chip dodd said
about fear he said
fear is your body's reaction literally
god gave us this emotion
to tell us that we are in need of
something and for me
in that moment i needed to focus on
truth
and the truth was i didn't need to be
afraid from a from a deep spiritual
element because i was kind of convicting
that moment for me those couple nights i
realized man maybe i've been putting too
much
value in my money in that right
i mean if that if that is shaking who am
i i mean all these questions were coming
in my head
but focusing on the truth you know psalm
says that the lord is with me and i will
not be afraid because when fear turns
into anxiety or paralyzing fear we don't
want that that's unhealthy
but i i'm telling you all of this
because so many of you
are experiencing a level of fear you're
experiencing a leveling
of anxiety maybe you're asking questions
like okay if something happens am i
going to be okay
maybe that time is running out i'm not
able to do the things that i want to do
what if i end up like my parents one day
what if what if what if and these and
these questions of fear
come up and i will tell you to combat
that fear number one with truth
but number two digging into why start
asking yourself those deeper questions
because when you can have self-awareness
on why you view money the way you do it
gives you this clear path
but the problem is is that we don't ask
those questions
the problem is is that we stay in this
and we don't go
underneath that foundation because we
talk about that personal finances 80
behavior it's only 20 head knowledge
and so tonight you're going to hear from
pastor craig and he's going to talk
about discipline
and systems it's going to help you with
your behavior hogan and dave they're
going to talk about getting out of debt
and budgeting and saving and giving
and all of these things are amazing but
again asking that
why question is so crucial because we go
through the motions of our life and we
don't ask that
you know if you go back and look over
the last year with your money
what are the questions that came up did
you ask why am i shopping more during
the pandemic than i ever did
why can't my spouse and i get on the
same page when it comes to money
why can i see not to live on a budget
why do i keep making the same money
mistake
over and over again why does my mom
keep telling me how to spend my money
and i'm a grown adult
why why why and so when you can start
understanding that
you come to a whole new level of
financial peace
you're you're able to understand
yourself and get out of debt
faster and permanently you're able to
partner with your spouse more
effectively you're able to build wealth
more quickly
and ultimately you're able to get to a
life that you get to live on your terms
and the life you feel like god is
calling you to and that money
is not your roadblock anymore so to get
to that
i want to walk through a couple of money
tendencies to help you really start
unpacking
and answering that question why so
there's seven money tendencies i talk
about my new book and we'll go over a
couple
tonight but but one of them pretty high
level is spender versus saver
so if i gave you a hundred dollars right
now what would you be tempted to do
would you be tempted to go out and spend
it or would you be tempted to kind of
save it in the bank
because the great thing about these
tendencies is neither one is right or
wrong
specifically in the money space people
like applaud savers
they got favors you're the you're the
blessed ones good job
good job and us spenders are somehow
evil or something no that's not the case
neither one is right or wrong
but the extremes on any of these
tendencies can be unhealthy and that's
where the red flag comes up that you
need to be aware of
so out of curiosity who in the room is a
natural saver
the responsible ones yes no
okay how many of you are a natural
spender like me
yes see we're kind of the fun ones right
i mean we just enjoy life it's great
it's great
but again watching out for these red
flags so in extreme for
for savers the extreme unhealthy side is
that you can hold money so tight and you
can have an
unhealthy relationship with it because
it becomes your security
full out that you you don't end up
opening that hand to give
and to enjoy the extreme end of the
spender
is that if we spend everything we make
we're gonna be broke right
we gotta reign it in and you gotta ask
your quest you gotta ask questions why
why am i spending 43 of americans said
they spent during the pandemic because
they were bored or stressed
and i probably added to that statistic
i'm not gonna lie
but really ask yourself do i am i
spending to feel good because when you
spend there's a scientific
studies that show yes dopamine hits like
it feels good doesn't it feels good when
you spend money it feels good
knowing that there's going to be an
amazon package coming to your door soon
it feels good so are you doing it to
cope
is that becoming your outlet ask
yourself
if nobody sees this purchase do i still
want it
if i can't post it on social media where
we're going do we still really want to
go
so so spenders ask yourself these
questions and when you get to those
extremes those red flags come up and
actually end up helping you
save money another tendency is
experiences or things
when you spend money do you tend to
spend it on experiences
this is more me i'd rather go out to a
great dinner go to the zoo with my kids
go on a nice vacation
where my husband he is a things guy
loves things he's like yes if i'm going
to work hard and spend my money i'm
going to spend it on something that i
want that i can use
over and over again like i look at our
christmas list what we want and i just
laughed because i was like i want a
massage and he wanted alexa light bulbs
that's it that's our marriage basically
so how many of you are experiences like
me you like
yes okay things people in the room
uh-huh if you're with your spouse are
you
are you seeing opposites here yes
so this is the one part of money and
marriage that you have to be careful
with because you
value what you're doing with your money
using money as a tool in your life
you value two different things and so
conflict
can arise so that is why it is so so
important that you work together as a
team that you budget together
that you have goals together you have
dreams together that you work together
verses apart another tendency is
quality or quantity quantity
so quality items you will spend
and it will be very nice this is my
husband he's like i just need two or
three nice pairs of boots that will last
me
where i'm a little bit more quantity i'm
like i'll have like 30 pairs of cheap
earrings
it's okay i don't need anything nice i'm
good i'm good so who who is quality in
the room you like your nice
things yes that's good okay quantity
okay you quality people you need to
watch out just to make sure
your red flag that when you spend the
money that you don't like kind of turn
your nose up and you're like no i have
to have the best of the best like
the tv has to be like the brand new
first edition because we're gonna we're
gonna use it a lot we're gonna use it a
lot right
or this brand i have to have this brand
and then
quantity people like me again we have to
be careful because we can justify
purchases so easily
i can say oh it's just 20 bucks it's
fine it's fine
and you just justify it i went through
the minimalist
challenge i don't know if you've heard
of the minimalists they're great guys
um out of california but they have a
great message about minimalism and i
really really appreciate
it because they have this challenge that
you take a month
of the year and whatever calendar date
is that day that you're on you give sell
or throw away
that number of items so on the first
it's one
on the second it's two three four five
and you go i mean
by the time it's like the 30th i'm
literally like finding like a bobby pin
and i'm like okay i don't need that i'm
good i don't need that
i it's hard it's really hard
but clearing out the stuff because i do
i can just get stuff in it oh it's
terrible
so watch out for that that's your red
flag for you quantity people
okay the last one is abundance versus
scarcity
abundance versus scarcity so abundance
people yes you see the glass half full
there's always more
more opportunity more choices more
options more money more and more we're
good
if i make a decision and it's wrong
let's make another one because there's
going to be another decision to make
it's fine
that abundance mindset now again the
extreme of that
you can live a little pollyanna thinking
it's all going to be fine
and then 2020 hits and it's not always
fine right
so watching out for that scarcity-minded
people again glass half empty
tend to hoard a little bit tend to keep
things close
some make some decisions based on fear
you don't take risks when you need to
that kind of thing
my mom sharon ramsey i wish people
knew more of her i wish she was out more
she like
doesn't care for the stage relevant
she's like i'm good i'm good i'm good
but mom is a saint we love my mom
and my mom grew up on a farm i mean
she's just like oh she's awesome
but mom self-admittedly leans on the
scarcity side of the scale i mean if you
open up her fridge she has leftovers
from like the past three nights
and always when we leave mom and dad's
house she's like trying to give me
three day old green beans she's like
just take it home just take it home i'm
like mom i'm good i'm good i'm really
good
but she's always a saver she always
finds ways okay you know that's just her
natural bent it is and i'll never forget
we went on a trip
when my sister my older sister got
pregnant and it was the first grandbaby
of the family this was seven eight years
ago
and we took a girls weekend trip away
and we mom and dad treated it treated us
which was very kind me and my sister so
we walked into the hotel and it was
my mom my sister and me beautiful room
we went to the beach it was so great so
nice and
denise and i were looking around the
hotel room and there in the center of
the hotel room
was a fruit basket on this table and
we're like oh
so we walk over was all wrapped take off
the card and it was from dad
he said girls have a great weekend away
enjoy it
have so much fun you know a very nice
note denise and i were like oh that's so
nice so we kind of walk away
well we hear this paper crinkling open
and we look over my mom's like oh girls
now we don't have to pay for breakfast
all weekend
who wants the kiwi
denise and i were like what denise was
like i'm five months pregnant i'm
getting omelets every morning and i was
like thank you jesus there's a huge yes
there's a pregnant woman on this trip
because mama's gonna make us eat this
bananas out of the fruit basket all
weekend and so
god love her though but yeah it's it's
that kind of stuff so you
you do have to watch yourself on these
tendencies so these tendencies i love
again not shameful no guilt in them
but it helps you recognize recognize why
you're doing the things you're doing and
ultimately gives you that level of
financial peace because you're
understanding yourself
but you're also having a level of
empathy with those in your life
those you're married to maybe your
parents maybe your grown kids your
friends
but under your understanding yourself
you're going to know your money
so much better and we talk about how
personal finance
is 80 behavior it's only 20 head
knowledge
so that behavior change is so key and
talking about discipline
and talking about systems one of the
best communicators on the planet right
now
a dear friend he is a national
bestseller and
head pastor of of life church absolutely
incredible
i can't wait for you to hear from him so
please welcome the stage pastor
greg groschel
thank you
[Music]
well how good is it to be together
and welcome all over the world online
how many of you want something different
for this year
want something different you want
something better ready for a little
reset what's interesting
when you look around almost everybody
wants similar things when you look at
the major things in life think about it
almost everybody you know wants
something similar
but the results are really really
different
for example if it comes to a marriage if
you
do get married chances are you want a
good
marriage how many you would like a good
marriage you want a good marriage i
don't know
anybody who says i want to fight all the
time
right my goal is to get a vpo filed
against me in two years or
less i hope to be divorced four times by
the time i'm 38 nobody says that
they want something similar but the
results are very different
the same is true with your health if i
ask you do you want to feel good do you
want to look good you want to be healthy
of course you're going to say yes
i don't know anybody who says i want to
feel miserable all the time
i want to get winded when i walk up a
single flight of stairs you know
i want to look bad on the beach in my
bikini nobody says that
we want similar things but the results
are very very different
the same is true with our finances
anybody wants a little bit of financial
breathing room
we want flexibility we want freedom
we want to be able to be a blessing i
don't know anybody who says
i want to worry all the time
my lifetime goal is to always live
paycheck
to paycheck i want to fight with my
spouse
i want to always be struggling my goal
is to file
bankruptcy by the time i'm 40. nobody
does that
we want similar things but the results
are
so so different and especially when it
comes to money
when we look at other people that have
what we want
we tend to either think they were lucky
or we don't like them
or both what i want to do is i want to
remind you that most of the time
they weren't just lucky what they were
most of the time is they were consistent
in fact when you look at almost any type
of successful person
what you're going to find in almost
every case
is that successful people do
consistently
what other people do occasionally when
you see
people who are financially blessed
most of the time you're going to see
people who have consistently done
wise things over a period of time
all of us will do good things
occasionally but what tends to happen is
the occasional people look at the
consistent people
and discount their consistency what we
have to do is we have to recognize
successful
people tend to do consistently what
others do occasionally
the challenge is that all of us we can
be a bit
inconsistent and in any area where we're
struggling to
achieve the life that we want or god
wants chances are pretty good
that we have some inconsistency why do
you think
that is why do we battle with
inconsistency
and there could be any number of reasons
but i'm going to give you two that are
pretty common why are we not as
consistent as we want to be number one
is many of you you're too focused on
what
to do you're too focused on what to do
and number two you've been trying for
too
long i'll unpack these number one
you're focused on what to do which isn't
a bad thing but perhaps there's a better
thing
most of us we're in a new year most of
us when we think
of goals we tend to think of do goals
what do you want to do
here's my do goal here's what i want to
do in the upcoming year which isn't bad
but i would suggest you something
different instead of starting with do
i'm going to suggest who before do
somebody say that we're going to
suggest who before do while most people
will ask what am i going to
do i'm going to suggest you start with
identity
and instead ask who do i want to become
there's a big difference it's not just
focusing on
actions but we're going to start with
identity because
identity tends to drive actions if we're
talking financially
instead of just saying here's what i
want to do i want to pay off
debt that's not a bad thing but that's
just a do
let's start with identity and ask who do
we want to become
and i don't know about you but i want to
be
debt free i want to be
irrationally generous i want to be in
control of my
money rather than having my debt
controlling and strangling me
before we start with just the do let's
take a step back
and talk about identity who do you want
to become
or even better yet who does god want me
to become we're going to start with the
who before the dew because
identity shapes actions
in other words when you know who you are
you'll know what to do why is it that
we're often
inconsistent for some of us we're too
focused on the do
and what i want to do is i want to talk
and focus more about the who
we'll come back to this thought in a bit
why are we inconsistent number one
we're too focused on the do number two
is many of you
you've been trying too hard you've been
trying for too long
and when you think about it in most of
the important areas of life
what do we tend to do we tend to try
to do better right if your marriage is
struggling a lot of times you try
to have a better marriage i'm trying to
be
nice or if you're a person of faith
sometimes you'll
try to start praying or you may try
to stop stop cussing or you may try to
be nice or try not to yell
at your kids or you try to stop spending
more than
you make the problem is for some of you
is you've just been trying for too long
what i want to encourage you to do is
this to stop
trying and start training
because there's a really really big
difference
i want to encourage you to stop trying
and start training
because trying never achieves consistent
results training achieves consistent
results
we'll talk for just a minute about the
difference between trying
and training i want you to think about
this if you're ever just
trying to do something i'm trying to
lose weight i'm trying to do a budget
i'm trying whatever
if you're trying that generally is this
to try is an attempt to change
with minimal commitment right it's kind
of like a half-hearted attempt well
i'm i'm trying i'm trying to get out of
debt you know i'm trying to do a budget
i'm trying to control my spending but
when you're trying honestly when i'm
trying
i've got plenty of room to fail there's
almost like a
built-in safety net to my language it's
not a full commitment
i'm i'm trying but i'm not fully bought
in
when i'm trying it's a it's an attempt
to change
with minimal commitment but to train is
different what is training
to train is a wholehearted commitment
to achieve a specific result
and you know the difference because if
you show up and you're just
trying you're kind of hoping for a good
result but if instead you show up and
you're
in training you've got a plan
you've got a strategy if you're training
in your finances you come up with a
budget
every dollar's got a name you got some
gazelle intensity
you got the eye of the tiger you got
rocky one rocky two rocky three rocky
four rocky five music playing
or cobra kai season three whatever it is
you're coming to play you're not showing
up trying to win you're training to win
and there's a vast difference in your
mindset when you're trying
you give up if it's too difficult
you give up if you don't feel like it
but when you're training
you don't act according to your feelings
you act according to commitment there's
a different mindset
when you're training can you guys handle
some bible
is that okay i'm the preacher in the
house so you got to bring
some bible if you're the preacher first
corinthians chapter 9
the apostle paul was talking to the the
corinthians and they would have known
about the olympic games that had gone on
for a long time or locally
they had what was known as the isthmian
games it was a uh
big competitive uh environment with
wrestling
and boxing and races and actually poetry
which is no joke so that's kind of funny
so if you're a poet you're a jock and
you didn't know it you're a poet you
didn't
jock and you didn't know it there's a
rhyme in there somewhere but i just blew
it okay
so here's what here's what the apostle
paul said
he said in 1st corinthians 9 he said do
you
not know that in a race
all runners run but only one gets the
prize
i love what he says run in such a way as
to get the prize
in other words if you're going to play
you might as well play to win
if you got a vision you're not trying
you're training and you want to bring
home the gold
he says everyone who competes in the
game goes into
strict training in fact they actually
did they had a very strict diet
they had no wine or alcohol they would
expose themselves
to extreme cold and extreme heat it was
a nine
month very intense training they go into
strict
training they do it to get a crown that
will not last
but for those of you who are people of
faith we have a higher goal
we do it to get a crown that will last
forever
what do they do if they're going into
competition
they're going into strict training
they're not trying to win
they're training to win in fact i like
the greek word this translated training
is the word agonizing
and it means to contend for victory
it means to strain every nerve
toward the goal i love this we're
training what are you doing
i'm training i know who i am
and i'm training to become more of who
i'm called to be
i'm not trying but i have an identity
i'm an athlete
who's in training imagine if you go to a
marathon
and you've trained and trained to train
and you stand next to someone else
and you lean over right before the gun
goes off he goes
have you been training and the other
person looks back and goes
nah haven't had time you're kidding me
what have you been doing uh well i was
i was going to but i just got busy i'm
here for the free t-shirt
and i'm going to try the best i can okay
you would look good
no way because
when you're an athlete when you're a
competitor
when you're fighting for something that
matters when you have a vision
when you have a goal when you're
compelled to do something that could
change your family
tree trying apart from training is
unthinkable
i want to encourage you stop trying and
start
training to become more of who you know
you
are and who you're supposed to be so the
apostle paul says this
he doesn't say so i run accidentally
hoping for a better tomorrow
i wake up and just be who i am
and let the wind takes me toward where
it is and when i see an
advertisement i hit click click click
click click don't no what he says is
i run with purpose
in every step when i take a step
there's purpose in it there's a
direction in it
every dollar has a name every step
has a goal i know who i am i'm running
with purpose in every step he says i'm
not just
shadow boxing now i love this i
discipline my body like a what let's all
say it aloud
i discipline my body like an athlete
training it to do what it should like an
athlete it starts with identity like an
athlete i'm training when you know who
you
are you'll know what to do identity
drives
actions paul doesn't say i'm trying
but he says i'm training some of you
it's time to stop trying
and start training i'm in training
somebody you say that i'm in training
just say that loud
i'm in training i'm gonna try if you're
training for a marathon and someone says
would you like a half a dozen donuts you
may want to normally but you can say
no why because i'm in training
if you see yourself as someone who is
debt-free
let no debt remain outstanding except
the continual debt to love
no more payments no more bondage no more
fights no more fears but you're becoming
more of what you're called to do and
someone says
do you want the sofa with no money down
and no payments until march you just say
no i'm sitting on my own ratty thing my
butt feels just fine on those springs
would you like the new purse no the new
shoes no the new watch though the new
car no the new boat with twin seadoos
yes but that'll be later
after i'm out of debt because when i
woke up today
i was in training and because i'm in
training there is purpose
in every single step it starts with
identity
who do you want to be when you know who
you are
your identity shapes your actions when
you know who you are
you'll know what to do we're going to
stop trying
because we're in training and with that
i want to pause for a moment and i want
to
take every bit of um humility and
gratitude on behalf
of my family and my six children
and say thank you to dave ramsey not
just my six children but my three
almost four grandchildren and some of
you say wow you've got six children and
almost four you must love
children the answer is yeah okay
i just really love my wife
and all god's people said hey man right
no i i like kids but i really like my
wife and and on behalf
of our family we just need to say thank
you because
uh dave helped me see who god wanted me
to be
and the year was probably 1993 and amy
and i had been married for two years
and we were driving down the road in a
christian
car we're in a 1989
honda accord and all the disciples
gathered in one
see what i did there okay and we were in
our little christian car and we turned
on this
radio station and we heard this wild man
i mean passionate and yelling and i
i could feel sweat flinging through the
radio ways
and he was telling you that's and then
that friend being free is is great and i
remember him saying if you'll just get
weird if you'll live like no one else
one day
you can live and give like no one else
and we just felt something resonate in
our spirits
and so in our early 20s before we had
too many years of dumb
we started undumb and dumb and started
consistently making weird decisions
my older kids looked back and said dad
we had no idea why our christmas
presents never came in boxes
and many of the parts pieces were not
there it was all garage sale
i was preaching away in clothes that
didn't fit
with the best money you could get at
secondhand clothing store year over year
over year
we were back in the day where we did um
the envelope budgeting system dave
taught us that now you can do it on your
computer so you don't know what an
envelope is
you can ask your grandma or google it
but that's we used to put our money in
envelopes and this was grocery money and
this was entertainment money and this
was
emergency fund money and little by
little by little by little by little
um we took a journey with purpose
in every step because we knew who we
were called to be
we knew who we wanted to become
so listen to me we weren't trying to get
out of debt we were in training it was
it was there was purpose in every step
and we had a little house that was about
valued
maybe seventy thousand dollars but on a
twenty four thousand dollar
income in just a few years of time by
the age of 27 we paid off
every single piece of debt including our
house
at the age of 27 with gazelle intensity
gazelle intensity and with purpose in
every single step so i want to say to
dave thank you for
helping us become who we're supposed to
become and i just want to take a moment
and review
let's talk about who before do
who do you want to become that's the
first question who do you want to become
who do you want to become we aren't
trying we're training and then you're
going to ask yourself
how are you going to train to become
that person
who do you want to become let's just
name it
and how are you going to train to become
that person because we know
that successful people do consistently
what other people do
occasionally and i believe with all my
heart it's time for a reset no more no
more bondage no more fear
no more anxiety about finances we're
going to dig in and say
we're not trying we're training and
we're going to live like no one else so
one day we can live
and give like no one else it is my
pleasure now to introduce to you
financial expert best-selling author of
the everyday millionaire the biggest man
in the house who is now my training
partner in jiu jitsu
for real please welcome chris hogan
i appreciate you man i appreciate you
hello everybody
oh how are you doing
i'm i'm going to tell you pastor craig's
got me pumped up to run a half k
i got a car shoot i don't know what he's
talking about all right
i'm so excited to be here can we talk
about how crazy this year has been
this past year is did insane i mean
whoever
thought that toilet paper and hand
sanitizer would become
volumes of money right it's insane
i mean i've smelled so much hand
sanitizer i can name the brand
right that's peril right there
that's the cheap stuff i'm staying away
from them they ain't killing no germs
right and toilet paper i'm telling you
you buy it in such big packs
you know i have a problem here's the
deal my boys i got three sons one of
them called down
he said daddy we're out of toilet paper
i'm like boy check your sock drawer
right oh yeah you gotta find creative
places to store this stuff right
putting it all over the place but i'm
excited to be here we've had a lot of
crazy things going on in this past year
and at this reset event i really want to
dig in and talk to you about a couple of
areas
that i know without a shadow of a doubt
will help you
have a financial reset we've had a lot
of things go on that we couldn't control
there's been crazy weather the pandemic
and boy there have been some crazy
people too can i get an amen
yeah i'm gonna tell you this i'm
grateful that the crazy people revealed
themselves
so i can stay away right and you all
don't act like this crazy is new to you
you
raise your hand if you got crazy in your
family okay
if your hand ain't up you might be the
crazy okay
i'm just here to tell you there's a lot
of things we couldn't control but i'm
here
to tell you without a shadow of a doubt
there are some things that we can
control
pastor craig was talking about training
having the mindset and i love that
because i want to
walk you through a process and a system
that will help you not only train you
but it's going to help you train your
money and so looking at this there are
some things we can control
i mean you think about it there's our
faith without a shadow of a doubt we're
in control of it
our attitude our outlook our responses
and more importantly my friends our
actions we can control these things
now crazy people are just going to be
crazy it's okay we'll pray for them
but what i want us to do is to remain in
control of the controllables
i've talked about a lot on this on my
show the chris hogan show
like yeah we can't get caught up in what
other people are doing
let's be sure to be aware we can't worry
about what's happening
in in the government because we all know
they're not going to save the day
see we have to take care of our house
and when we take care of these things we
remain in control
and so one of the actions that i want to
dig in with you tonight and talk about
is the action of taking control of our
money i want to talk about budgeting
now i know typically when i say that
word people start twitching
they're like oh hogan those are
handcuffs no
literally i want to show you as you walk
through this process
when you learn to budget you're going to
give yourself a raise
you're going to give yourself an
understanding of exactly what's going on
and i think it's important for us to do
that and we're talking about
training i mean listen to me this money
stuff is not going to happen overnight
but you've got to train yourself to
learn and as pastor craig was talking
about
train to become don't just try
and this is the year i think the perfect
time for us
to get more intentional with the doing
and less talking about trying
we can do this and it's going to take
some discipline it's going to take some
time
but i'm going to tell you this i've got
three boys and when they were younger
they were six five and four first and
foremost don't do that
okay no i'm just here to tell you give
this yourself some space
okay don't don't do that but when they
were young we used to huddle up
i'd huddle up with them i'm a former
linebacker i know y'all see me up here
in my skinny jeans
and think y'all laughed in my face
i mean i played football back in the day
so i'm used to being like this this is a
linebacker position
and so the boys we would huddle up
before we went into the restaurants
because i needed them to understand a
few things right
you got kids y'all know and so you
huddle up i was like all right boys
listen
you've been in a restaurant before
okay we're going in here to eat the food
we don't throw the food we don't yell
and we go through and my my middle child
is wired like me he's my mini me he'd
say daddy can i do it i'd say all right
son go ahead he put his hand he'd say
one two three break
and then we'd go in the restaurant and
my boys would act like they'd been there
before
now what's funny is is when they're that
age and they saw other kids
misbehaving they'd say daddy look at
that little boy over there acting a fool
which cracked me up right but what's
funny is is my middle my mini me
he's the one he'd say daddy look at that
little boy rack thank you food then you
go like this
right we huddle up
we got to set expectations lay the
groundwork lay down the rules and the
guidelines so we know what's going on so
everybody
can have a good time i'm talking about
huddling up
like that with my kids but i want you to
do that with your money
i literally want you and your spouse to
huddle up
before the month begins and begin to
talk about what's coming in
what's going out what do we got to do
and i'm going to tell you that huddle up
changes the
game because your spouse shouldn't be
your opponent
it needs to be your best teammate and
what we have to do is work hard for that
we don't naturally grow together we
naturally grow apart
we've got to intentionally grow together
and so working with this budget i'm
going to tell you
there's a name for money that's not on a
plan you know what it's called
spent yeah it'll go somewhere you've
seen it the sales and the stores they
just get you
what i want you to do is have more
control and so being smart
we all know there's these big old
grocery stores you all got costco and
sam's
you know there's great there's fantastic
but you got shopping carts in there that
require a cdl license to drive
like this too big i don't and what if
you can go down the aisle and snatch up
some eggs on al2
don't be able to grab a couch on all
three right i need some space
give me some variety or something right
we got to be smart
and so in grocery stores i've been
intentional i'm telling you
training getting healthier but i found
in tennessee we got oreos that have legs
they just jump up in my cart right and
they need a home they're homeless oreos
i got to help them
right
pray for me
but listen to me here's what i figured
out about myself i was ashamed of my
grocery budget
you know why because i was shopping out
a habit not out of need
and i wasn't bothering anybody i had the
money my money wasn't bothering anybody
the problem was is when my reality check
is that i realized i'm helping the
grocery store build wealth
and i'm going broke costco sams and all
of them they're going to be okay
hold on i'm an equal opportunity
offender publix kroger and everybody
else out there
right but don't shop out a habit just
because saturday morning is your time to
go to the grocery store
you don't have to buy everything that's
in there and just because it's on sale
doesn't mean it needs to go on your cart
so we got to learn how to play defense
my friends and so
shopping out a habit let's go nip that
in the bud and change it this year
so i want to give you four components of
every budget
looking at this walking through what i'm
telling you right now is going to give
you awareness
number one is your income you need to
know how much is coming in
number two is your giving your tithe or
the charities that you're supporting
then you're saving and then you're
spending
these four areas are things that you can
have control over
and remember we are training so we're
going to be intentional with it
you can do this and so setting spending
limits on certain things will give you
boundaries
and i'm going to tell you something i
brought out something i've been talking
about these grocery stores they give out
samples
honey don't even get happy okay i'm on a
budget
you not getting this okay
but have you ever how many of y'all have
kids raise your hands okay how many have
two or more
three or more oh y'all fertile okay
don't you wish your kids would behave
like don't it it's amazing isn't it they
can come from the same dna but be wired
totally different
but i'm going to tell you something
unlike kids money will behave
it'll sit still and obey if you tell it
to watch this
stay now this benjamin
better not leave my hand why because i
didn't give it permission to
and it'll go where i tell it to go and
it'll go when i tell it to go
see that's the kind of mindset you have
to have about your money
too many of us are walking around with
our purses and our wallets just held
wide open and stores are just
coming coming and taking no we're going
to play defense
we're going to get smart and so i'm
going to tell you six steps to doing a
budget walk with me here
number one you're going to start with
your income how much is coming
in single income double income it
doesn't matter you need to know how much
is coming in
next you're going to list all of your
expenses your utilities
your rent your cell phone gas you're
gonna list out everything
and then you're gonna subtract expenses
from your income
okay so you know exactly where you stand
and then once you do that
you're gonna track your expenses you're
gonna make sure hey are we staying on
target
are we being smart about some things and
then finally be flexible
now being flexible is important because
you're going to have to learn how to
turn some things off so you can turn
some other things on
meaning hey you know what this is all we
allotted for eating out we're going to
shut that down
like you got to be smart about that uh
back in the day i used the envelopes
and and the envelope system was a game
changer for me because when the money
was gone out of the envelope
that meant there was no more doing that
thing
and my boys love to go to eat out after
church and they're like dad
can we go out to eat i was like hold on
let me check the envelope
and the envelope when i opened it up air
and moths came out
right nothing in there i was like yep
well we're going to a new restaurant
they're like what's the name of it i was
like mikasa
and they were happy for about 60 seconds
and they've been taking spanish they're
like wait a minute me and casa that's
house
oh dad i was like yup that's where we're
going
and what they did was help them to
understand that if there's no money then
there's no doing
and if a child can understand that as
adults we have to be able to
right we've got to be able to tell
ourselves no and so i want to take you
through an example of a budget
and i talk about this but i want you all
to understand as a part
of ramsey plus you're going to get every
dollar which is the best budgeting tool
on the planet
remember we're training we're training
and having discipline so you're going to
have to learn how to do this budget
but inside of ramsey plus you all are
going to get this and have an
opportunity
to really plug in and learn so i want to
show you an example budget real quick
now calm down i'm not going to nerd out
too much on you but we've got to see
this so we can put it into action
so let's start with income let's say
it's 3 500 is how much is coming in
then we said we were going to list all
expenses so let's list them out
you've got your giving that's at the top
because that should be a priority
next you got your saving of 450 dollars
you've got
rent of 875 dollars you've got utilities
of 350
and then you've got groceries slash
restaurants as 525
transportation paying for gas and cars
350
insurance 500 and then miscellaneous
100.
so we're subtracting our in our expenses
from our income
this should all equal zero that's why we
call it a zero-based budget
we're giving every dollar a name and a
destination
so as you do this you'll be aware
tracking your expenses throughout the
month will help you tighten up your
budget
or be able to tighten down some areas
that need to be but let's take a look at
this
because this budgeter forgot something
they're debt
so we got to go back we got to go back
and make some changes
right we can't forget about debt we got
to take care of that so they got a car
payment of 325
and a student loan of 150
so we got to go back to the budget and
find some money so look at this
saving got chopped down to 200 and
groceries went from 525 to 300
to take care of the car payment and the
student loan
see this is the kind of fluidity the the
reality the living breathing thing that
the budget is
that you have the ability to make
changes and updates
and that's what i want you to hear too
many people try the budget for a little
while and they get frustrated and
irritated
or they try it for a few minutes and
decide to give up
no more try let's do and so looking at
this it'll allow you put it to put it
into place
and so sticking to a budget it's going
to take about three months you all
three months before you get it down pat
but hear me
this budgeting skill is a skill that's
going to follow you through
the rest of your financial life it's
going to set you up to live your dreams
it's going to set you up to be more
generous with people and charities
and things that you believe in more than
you ever thought possible
so it is something that's imperative
that you have to do and so looking at
this i want to share with you a few
things because
the food item was my stupid area that's
i told you guys i confessed that to you
already
but i want to give you a few things
three things you can do
with the food budget that will help you
win number one
make a grocery list okay
open up some of y'all have that can of
wax beans
or pork and beans that have moved with
you three times
okay the label's so tired it's fallen
off
eat that stuff like meal plan make a
plan so
look at your refrigerator make a list of
what you're going to buy
here's the kicker and this is what i'm
telling myself stick
to the list if it's not
on the list don't buy it i don't care
about the sale sign
don't look if it's not on the list don't
buy it and
stick to the amount that you said you
were going to on the budget
okay so for groceries don't you buy that
five dollar can of corn
you have two dollar can corners fine
okay be smart
but stick to your dollar amount and what
i did the game changer for me
i went in with cash this is where i took
back my financial future
i set up how much i was gonna spend i
made a list and i went in with cash
that meant i couldn't overbuy i couldn't
overspend no i didn't want to be that
person at the counter
looking like boo boo the fool because i
can't pay for the stuff right oh no i
was focused look
i had my phone and my little calculators
before phones i had my calculator
and i was added up bumped into a friend
messed around and hit reset on the
calculator
oh
and my first thought was oh i'll just
use the debit card
i ain't got it i left it at home
i brought 150 cash this was my big boy
moment
what'd i do do you go up to the counter
and hope and pray
baby jesus wasn't gonna show up there
what did i do i put everything back and
started over
it was my grow up moment i'll never
forget that saturday at 10
35 a.m no because the starting over what
did i do
i made a declaration this is what i'm
going to do
i'm doing this and i can and starting
over
and i checked out at 140.59
and you'd have thought i'd hit the
powerball when i walked out of there
because it was one of those things where
i knew i could do this i just had to
break the habits
and so i'm just telling you because i
want you to have that moment
i want you to have that moment where you
take that stand where you only shop and
buy the things on the list
or you only spend what you said you were
going to spend and i'm telling you
i want you and your spouse to celebrate
that because that's a start point
all right looking at this you got to be
smart being intentional you you have to
make budgeting a habit
i did the largest study we did ramsey
solutions the largest study of
millionaires that's ever been done
for my book everyday millionaires we
talked over 10 000 of them
but get this statistic 93 of the
millionaires say that they stick to the
budgets they make
so it's not an accident and i'm not
talking about you doing this just for
fun
or just a declaration what i'm saying is
i want you to build that muscle
to build that habit to where you are in
control
budgeting will give you peace of mind
and it will help you relax
more than you've ever known now let me
shift to the next topic
savings savings what we have seen the
personal savings rate in the united
states
look at this it has absolutely it
spiked back in april because that was at
the height of the pandemic
for over 25 years ramsey solutions has
been talking about having an emergency
fund
it's important to have an emergency fund
it's important it's important it's
important
we have never had more brand validation
than ever before than last year people
all of a sudden were like
you know about that emergency fund
that's a good idea
and i'm like yes inside i'm like this
duh
come on look smart but look at this
that's in april 33.7
look where it is now it's dropped back
down to 13.6 see we've normalized again
okay we we we're we've forgotten and
it's amazing how fast we can get amnesia
and amnesia is part of being stupid
and what we have to do is stop that we
got to look and go no no no
no it is important to have an emergency
fund so what we have to do is learn how
to save
but hear me saving can't be accidental
it needs to be intentional okay it has
to be intentional that you're looking at
this and going no no
we got to be smart back to my study 97
of millionaires believe that they
control their own destiny
it means they're not trying they're
doing and so in looking at this with
budgeting and talking about saving don't
try
i want you to do you see when you pile a
big pile of cash
up what happens is when you have an
emergency
it's just a simple inconvenience you
don't have to run to the bank you don't
have to pick up the phone to call
anybody
you've set aside a cushion to protect
you and it's imperative
budgeting will help you take care of the
necessities saving will prepare you for
an emergency
and so the goal is to attack debt and
then build up
a serious fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
see this is the thing we're talking
about to be able to save and protect you
now hear me we want to save for three
reasons
purchases and spending okay a little
lady came up to me i was on book tour in
denver years ago for my first book
retire inspired
and she had on flip-flops you know when
somebody is walking with attitude with
flip-flops because you can hear them
popping
awful fast right little bitty woman and
you i could hear her coming she was like
pop
pop pop pop pop and she rolled up on me
she was about this tall
and had big attitude she said
christopher hogan
you and dave ramsey i have a problem
with y'all and i bent down
and i said oh ain't you cute
and i like i started to pick her up but
that's a violation you can't do that
i left that bent down people don't look
at me like that and i said oh honey
what's wrong she goes y'all don't want
nobody to have no stuff
and i just looked at her and i wanted to
pat her on the head but i didn't i said
oh baby no
i want you to have nice stuff dave wants
you to have nice stuff
we just don't want the stuff to have you
and when you have to work hard and leave
the people you love your family
to go work to pay for some stuff that
don't count that's a problem
and so i want you to pay cash for stuff
i want you to get in the habit of paying
cash
for small medium and large things like
small things like birthday parties
never forget i was on a budget i was
getting intentional with money and my
kids every time it turned around they
were coming home
with some kind of birthday party
invitation and that you know you buy a
birthday gift for a kid that's 20 30
they were hitting the budget and finally
i told them all three of them i said
come here sit down
i got the daddy tone they knew something
was wrong i was like listen
quit being so nice in school
i'm like you get one friend that's it
blowing up my budget no i'm just playing
pay cash for stuff people small stuff
medium wash your dryer break down
you don't have to trip you don't have to
flip out you just go get the money
out of the emergency fund you go pay
cash for it i'm gonna tell you one of my
big other big boy moments
the first one was the grocery store you
know the second one was
paying cash for my first car
game changer game changer for this
little old kentucky boy
i'm little on the inside people i'm a
little on the inside
but to save up the cash and pay cash for
that vehicle
was a game changer for me because i
realized yes i can do this
and i know without a shadow of that if i
can do it i know you can
but what we have to do is prove to
ourselves we have to take that step
so you can pay cash another thing i want
you to say for is emergencies
life happens watch this raise your hand
if you've had a car repair in the last
12 months
okay see there it is if your hand ain't
up you own the clock okay i
you know it just happens right i'm not
putting that on your car baby jesus
bust his cars watch over him watch over
we gotta save for emergencies because
life is gonna happen you know that
some of y'all been saying prayers every
morning as you walk toward that card and
hope it starts
right okay well at some point you're
gonna need a battery people you just are
another thing you say for is wealth
building and this is an area i'm
absolutely passionate about i talk about
it on the chris hogan show
with callers all the time because i know
without a shadow of a doubt
if you don't save and invest for the
future you're not going to have anything
to spend and those kids and grandkids
that you love so much
the last thing you want to do is be a
burden for them
so it's imperative for us to take care
of our financial future
so we save for purchases we save for
for uh emergencies and we save to build
wealth
now these last several months we've seen
a lot of things happen that are outside
of our control
but i want you to hear me with this
budgeting will give you more control
over your money
than you ever imagined you just have to
begin to do it
don't try it will the other thing is is
saving
will give you more peace of mind than
you ever thought possible
because when you have that fully funded
emergency fund and something breaks down
all you have to do is just get the money
and fix it
you don't have to call family you don't
have to call a bank
and you don't have to sit in that loan
office while somebody's judging you
to see if you're worthy see it's time
for us to take back control
it's time for you to start to believe in
you and what you can do
but you need a system that will work and
ramsay plus is that system
these principles have changed my life
okay i've lived them it changes things
it helps you to see things totally
different
and it will give you more control so no
more wondering
no more guessing what i want you to do
is to be about doing
for you the people you love and also the
things that you care about
this year's past year has been crazy and
we don't know what's coming in this year
but you and i do know who holds the
future can i get an amen
and i can't be scared if i've got him in
my corner and i want you to have that
mindset of understanding as you budget
and as you save
it's you being a good steward of what
you've been blessed with please don't do
like i did years ago and say
when i start making more i'll get more
serious i'm not going to ask for a show
of hands because there'll be too many
that pop
up but i'm here to tell you if you can't
manage 40 well
why would he bless you and give you 50.
okay
if you can't start right where you are
why would he
now i'm not saying that he would
withhold from you what i'm saying is is
when you start to get intentional with
the plan
you're going to feel more in control and
that 40 can feel like 50 when you get
more intentional
because it's not an accident anymore so
i want you to believe
i know we all get that little sound in
the back of our head that can tell us
you can't do it or you shouldn't try and
i want you to mute that voice
it's time to play another track it's
time for you to find your hopes and
dreams you just have to give the effort
have the discipline be willing to stay
focused and most importantly if you're
married
work together no more things in the
middle of you get serious get connected
at the heart
and work if you're newly single or
single find an accountability partner
somebody that loves you
believes in you and wants you to be
successful i know you can do this
budgeting will give you power saving
will give you peace
you can do this and we're here to help
all right you all dave ramsey's about to
come back out
this man has devoted his life to
chopping down myth so people can
understand the truth
he's devoted his life to helping people
to have a plan so they can have a path
and he's about to come out and tell you
a couple more principles that will help
you change the game
so without further ado you all help me
welcome back to the stage
mr dave ramsey
[Applause]
appreciate your brother appreciate it
yeah
chris hogan
[Applause]
so who knew that tonight your reset was
going to be that the third pig is in
training
and he has an abundance or a scarcity
mentality we're just not sure about all
this
the interesting thing for me i'm a math
nerd as i started studying these money
things after i went broke and i said
i'm going to learn god's ways of
handling money i'm going to learn
grandma's ways of handling money
i want to talk to old rich people i have
been young and rich i didn't want his
opinion
so i want to talk to old rich people
people that have what's known as wisdom
gray hair or no hair
i want to talk to people who have done
it not people who've got an opinion
i got to thinking about it my my finance
professor in college is who taught me to
go into debt
use debt it's a powerful tool you can
lift things with debt and he was broke
what's wrong with this picture a broke
finance professor
it's like a shop teacher with missing
fingers
so with my finance degree and all these
letters and licenses after my name there
i sat broke
and i started studying these things
almost 30 years ago
and i came to this mathematical insight
it'll blow your mind
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income and when you give it to
someone else
you don't have it anymore wow
that was deep
your most powerful wealth building tool
the consistency throughout your life
to build wealth is your income and when
you give it to someone else
you don't have it anymore you will never
win with money to the extent you embrace
staying in debt you can rationalize it
you can justify it you can believe all
the mythology that's out there
or you can just go i want my money back
you ever get something where you got
ripped off and you go to the counter
i want to talk to the manager i want my
money back
that's the st that's the status you need
to put yourself in i want my money back
i work too hard to be broke
i want my money back i've been ripped
off
too long i want my life back
you got to get in this mode where you
say i'm sick and tired
of being sick and tired the great
motivator les brown used to say people
don't change their lives on theory
they don't change their life on
intellectual and academic exercise
people change their lives when they
finally get to the point they say
i've had it 20 20 woke me up
i want to reset i've had it
no more when you get to that
you're ready but until you do
this is just an intellectual exercise
and you'll be trying
instead of training see debt is a
relatively new concept in america
you go back 75 years it almost didn't
exist you go back 100 years and hardly
existed at all
there were no standardized mortgages if
you were in debt on a mortgage in the
year 1910
people looked down on you like you had
done something wrong like you sinned
and then baby boomers come home from
world war ii baby boom starts happening
and we standardized mortgages in the 50s
and 60s
and then we standardized credit cards in
the 70s and then we standardized student
loans in the 70s and 80s
and then we've standardized this idea
that it's
normal to be in debt and oh by the way
normal is
broke and sucks so who wants to be
normal
we've normalized this stupidity and
here's the thing you live in the most
aggressively marketed
to culture in the history of the world
i mean they know have you ever noticed
that even when you just start talking
about something it starts popping up on
your computer
it's a little spooky people
i mean it's like the billboards on the
highway start lining up with everything
oh man it's ridiculous they're selling
me stuff 24 7
all day long and you know what the most
aggressively marketed product
by dollars the most money is spent to
sell
this product of any product in the most
aggressively marketed to
product or culture in the history of the
world the most aggressively marketed
product is debt
four companies mastercard
visa american express and discover
spent four billion dollars
a year selling you
on how badly you need them and guess
what when they sell you something you
know what happens you buy it
and you buy it and you buy it and you
buy it now let's put four billion
dollars in perspective just a second
okay
average house in america today now i
know there's california and i know
there's manhattan i know real estate
prices okay
but the average house price in america
today is just over two hundred thousand
dollars
four billion dollars would buy 20
000 houses
of two that's what they spent to sell
you 20 000 houses
to sell you and they're good at it baby
they know what they're doing
so the idea even the concept of living
without debt oh dave you're just a
troglodyte do you drag your knuckles you
really don't understand you're primitive
you don't understand you know you don't
get this thing sophisticated people
i mean you're going upstream when you
start talking about
being debt free 100 because it is so
normalized
i get hate mail because i cut up
credit cards
think about how weird that is
i mean that tells you how sold you
people are
people love their freaking credit cards
to the point they hate me if i suggest
you butcher them
this is weird but it tells you how deep
these
claws are into the psyche of who we are
in america today
and i'm walking around trying to pry
these claws off a single mom so she can
eat
off a young couple so they don't get a
big fight about money one too many times
and
in their marriage i gotta get i gotta
get people's got to get the claws off of
you
that's my job is to pry them off one at
a time
it's ridiculous it requires a completely
new way of looking at things
to even consider the idea of getting out
of debt
when you get a new way of looking at
things back in the 80s there was a
phrase that went around
last year the phrase was pivot right
we pivoted so much i felt like i had one
leg right i mean we
an unprecedented right are you sick of
those two words i'm sick of those two
words
but pivot pivot the big word back in the
80s was
paradigm shift anybody remember that
you need a paradigm shift well your
paradigm is just your set of glasses
that you use to look at look at the
world through
and so what that means is if you have a
paradigm shift you have a new way of
looking at things have you ever
you know how you get a new way of
looking at things you learn something
that you didn't know
have you ever read for instance
scripture in the bible any of you that
are believers like me
and you read it and five years later you
read the exact same passage and it means
something different to you
and all that is is your paradigm your
way of looking at things your position
of seeing it
is a different angle that's all that
means and so you need a paradigm shift
so that's what we have to have about
that so just to show you how learning
works when you
learn you get a new way of looking at
things here's a visual paradigm
take a look at this one
yeah before you get the noose out and
want to hang me you better do your
punctuation
before you cancel old dave you better do
your punctuation right
isn't it interesting that with no
punctuation you saw one or the other
and you read it with the wrong emphasis
on the right emphasis in case you didn't
know the last one is the correct one but
now that you've seen the punctuation in
both of them you'll never see that
phrase again
without remembering this you've had a
paradigm shift
learning gives you a new way
of seeing things and that's what we're
doing with the reset
learning the being on a budget learning
that training with consistency
versus trying is the way to do this
learning that there's a spectrum between
spender and saver
and both are okay learning tonight gives
you your reset
it sets you in a completely different
place here's another paradigm shift look
at this one careful
the rituals over the poor and the
borrower is
slave to the lender
now with several hundred thousand people
watching this all over the world i'm
well aware
that some of you in this room and a lot
of you watching probably aren't people
of faith like i am
but i'm what's called an old-fashioned
christian
and that means i believe the bible and
not only do i believe it
as an act of faith and walking in it and
walking with god now for 30 some odd
years
but i also have seen it proven out to be
true
see i've seen this phrase when you're
not a slave anymore
you know what people do they yell i'm
dead free
it's a visceral reaction to be set free
so it must be slavery
and by the way if you don't have any
money because you gave it all to someone
else
you don't have any choices because you
gave all your choices to someone else
because you spend like you're in
congress
[Applause]
when you do that you set yourself up to
fail
and you're going to lose it changes
everything
the borrower is slave
to the lender and i'll tell you when you
know that
when you know that you know whether
you're a person of faith or not you'll
believe that
the truth of that statement when you pay
off your home
as your last debt and you take off your
shoes
and you walk through the backyard and
that grass under your feet feels
different
there's something lifts off your
shoulders that you didn't even realize
you were carrying
think about what it would be like to
have no payments
no master card
no discovered bondage no american
distress
sally may gets her eviction notice
and you own your house interesting thing
we've done detailed research at ramsey
solutions
and we have found that 100 of the
foreclosures occur on a home with a
mortgage
it releases you in your spirit in your
heart your chest will
lighten up you'll breathe different it
changes everything it is
more than just math it's more than just
an intellectual financial argument
there's a spiritual element an emotional
element a relational element
there's a sense of freedom it changes
you
it puts you in a different position well
dave everybody has a credit card
i know and everybody's broke
and you know i've been doing this for a
long time you guys i've met with
thousands and thousands of millionaires
i never met a single millionaire said
dave you know i made it all with my
airline miles
those discover points they put me right
over the top man
i've never heard that one time so we're
suggesting the idea that
maybe not maybe for sure
it's time for a plasectomy it's time for
plastic surgery
i mean get it out citibank what's in
your wallet
money
unbelievable man american distress gold
plastic
discover freedom target
bank of america why would anybody do
business with
unbelievable man nothing down
furniture i can get me that yeah
what's the interest rate on your credit
card dave zero i don't have one
you don't have a credit card no i went
broke 30 years ago they wouldn't give me
one
bankruptcy will solve that for you
and then years later when i was able to
qualify which was about 16 seconds after
i filed bankruptcy they started sending
credit cards again
that's how it really works in the real
world
i decided the borrower slave lender i'm
not going back
i'm going to have a reset never again
never again if american express calls my
house it's a wrong number
never again am i going to sit and wonder
and fret
never again is sally may going to have
her thumb on me or my family
we're breaking the chains on this family
tree i'm done with this
i'm not living like this anymore never
again you don't have a credit card no
that's my wallet
green president's faces four pieces of
plastic
the debit card on my personal account
the debit
card on my business my
driver's license and my handgun carry
permit
so
[Applause]
well
[Music]
it's okay you're safe it's all right
don't just calm down
you'll be okay well everybody's got a
car payment dave
no they don't when we did that study
chris hogan was talking about for
everyday millionaires the data says
that the average millionaire by the way
90 of them started with nothing and
became millionaires they didn't inherit
it that's the great lie that goes around
with the political agenda
absolutely out of hand of the of the
10 000 millionaires that we studied the
largest study of millionaires
ever done in north america airtight
research technique
unbelievable because we knew we could be
criticized so believe me you can't mess
with this research we own it it's
awesome
we own you if you think you're going to
mess with it it's unbelievable
as we studied them you know how many of
them carry a car payment
none not one well i wouldn't either if i
was a millionaire you missed the point
[Applause]
the average car payment in america today
is 526
over 84 months according to the national
auto dealers association you know what
526 dollars invested from age 30 to age
60 is
5.2 million dollars in your roth ira
hope you like the car
guy call me up on my show and he's like
dave i got a big old truck payment
i said how much is your truck payment
man well man it's texas
what's texas got to do with it
they got stupid in every state man how
big is your truck payment
763 dollars i'm like oh
dude how much is your car how much is
your house payment well we live in a
double wide it's 550.
i'll always have a job
wow
man me and me and jenny craig we got a
lot of work to do i'm just saying
oh wow i said man if your truck payment
is bigger than your house payment you
might be a redneck
wow you're always going to have a car
payment
that says i'm always going to be middle
class
and there's no there won't be a middle
class
but if you're going to do it do it on
purpose don't do it as a victim
i can't get out you ever hear people say
i grew up people say
the little man can't get ahead
who's this little man i've been looking
for him everywhere
hogan talked about the little woman in
the flip-flops but i've never seen the
little man
a little man can't get who's that little
man i grew up around
i mean i grew up in a subdivision in a
thousand square foot house i don't know
how you grew up
the guys i work grew up with worked at
the railroad they you know
they cut hair they you know they were
working people
uh who's this little man little man
can't get ahead what is ee or your
spirit animal i mean come on
well dave you got to keep your credit
score up yeah that's a great idea
your credit score uh mathematically is
composed of elements
only that relate to debt
100 of the mathematical algorithm that
they used to create your fico score
has to do with you borrowing money how
much did you borrow what kind of debt
did you pay it back on time it's an i
love debt score so the more you've been
playing kissy face with the bank
the bigger a number you got i got a 800
credit score man i'm really sorry
that probably cost you a hundred grand
in interest cause you've been playing
kissy face a lot i mean you're like in
make out mode with the bank right here
man
this is unbelievable i worship at the
altar of the great fico he brings me
things
he allows me to do things that i could
not do without the great fico
and yet i've not had a fico score for 30
years and i'm doing pretty good
but i don't need to borrow money
and see it's an interesting it's a dog
chasing this tail you got to get a
credit card so you can get a credit
score so you can get a car
so you can get a house so you can get a
credit score and you need to go into
debt so that you can go into debt so
that you can go into debt
sounds like a scam to me
what a great if i was a bank and i could
get you people to believe
that your net worth was not as important
as your fico score
then you would go deeply in debt for the
rest of your life and build towers
in the skyline of every city while you
can't make your bills
what a great idea
and yet we go well dave those people
that stay out of debt they're
unsophisticated
i beg to differ it might be the other
way around
it might be the other way around so how
do we get out of that well there's some
things we've discovered that'll get you
out of that
let me tell you another one that's just
really insightful the first thing that
gets you out of debt is quit borrowing
more
if you just stop borrowing and pay your
payments eventually you'll get out
42.4 years on credit cards sallie mae
you'll be 31 years
your mortgage will be 30 or 15 depending
on which one you took
and your car payment will run out but
you'll probably go get you another one
of those because you just love it
so if you'll just quit borrowing money
eventually you will wander out
but it's a big step you got to say
that's it
as for me and my house we're done
we're done no
no it's a neat word it'll set you free
i'm going to live like no one else so
that later i can live and give like no
one else
i'm going to pay the price to win and
then when i win people are going to say
you're so lucky and i'm going to say
luck had nothing to do with it darling
we were kicking butt and taking names
that's how we got here
you're lucky lucky's butt any luck on
this at all
you quit borrowing more money second
thing is you need to save money chris
talked about this
you need to build your emergency fund
the first step we teach you in ramsey
plus
in financial peace university is baby
step one get you a thousand dollar
starter emergency fund then you work
your way out of that debt
as soon as the debt's gone everything
but the house that snowball we'll talk
about that in a few minutes then you're
gonna go to baby step three and you're
gonna have a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
you'd be in a different place in 2020 if
you had a big old emergency fund
you would have gone into debt oh wow we
were in a pinch
lost my job had to use credit cards to
live on
well how you got thirty thousand dollars
in credit card debt in four months
what did you make a month uh well
we made two thousand dollars a month
well four months of that would be eight
thousand dollars so you got thirty
thousand dollars in credit card debt
so you didn't go into debt because you
lost your job you went in the debt cause
you went
cray-cray
the next thing you need to do is sell
something sell so much stuff the kids
think they're next
name the dog ebay put the cat on
craigslist
come here rover
i mean just start moving some stuff it's
just stuff
you can get some more stuff
and stuff
people act like that they married their
car
it's an emotional event to sell a stupid
car
there's a car everywhere it's a car i
love cars i'm a boy i like things with
motors and
loud mufflers and i'm a redneck i really
like big mufflers on my truck you know
but man it's just a car
it's just a car get you another one
don't let it own your future
sell it i don't know what you got to
sell you can decide all that when you
get into the details
to sell something take a part-time job
or
pick up a bunch of overtime
my grandmother used to say there's a
great place to go when you're broke to
work
[Applause]
pray prayer really works
i already discounted and already put the
caveat out there that i'm well aware
everybody's not
watching this is not necessarily a
christian like me i'm not mad at you
about that it's okay i get it i
understand but i got to tell you whether
you believe it or not your heavenly
father
is absolutely crazy about you
he he thinks you're amazing
dave i i could i hadn't talked to him in
years i couldn't talk to him i
if i i mean you don't know about all the
dumb stuff i've done
honey let me just tell you you get
enough kids
you're going to get a stupid one
now think about it don't you know your
heavenly father's got some stupid
children
how many of you at one time or another
like me have been one of his stupid
children right
so i mean sometimes you know he's just
up there laughing with gabriel he's like
look at that
that's funny now i'm just saying it's
going to leave a mark
it's going to leave a mark he's not
going to forget that one
when we're made in his image we laugh so
you know he's laughing
a lot he's not mad at you honey
if you messed up and done some stuff you
shouldn't have done well welcome to the
human race
he's not mad at you just misses you
phone home e.t
check in prayer
really works
so then we're going to use the debt
snowball we're going to list our debts
smallest to largest we're going to pay
minimum payments on everything but the
little one and we're going to attack
the little one with a vengeance i want
my life
back you people have had it long enough
i want my
income my most powerful wealth building
tool back in my control
we're gonna change this family tree it
stops here
somebody in the vanderbilt line had to
be old man vanderbilt
somebody in the morgan line had to be
old man morgan
somebody in the rich family of your
dreams line
had to be the first one that said enough
why not you draw a line in the sand
enough
list your debts smallest to largest
attack that smallest one with a
vengeance
when it's gone you're going to go well
look at there and then you're going to
have all that money that was that
payment and any other money you squeeze
out of that chris hogan budget
and you attack the next one down and
you're selling stuff and you get a bonus
and you get a little small inheritance
you hit it
boom it's gone when those two are gone
you take the payment from that one you
go to the third one when those three are
gone you take the payment from those
three that snowball picks up steam
and it goes another one when you start
you'll be kind of mildly amused
by the time you get down and you start
really believing this is going to happen
and hope kicks in
and you start to really believe this is
not theory i'm really going to make it
i'm really going to get out i see the
finish line you know what you're going
to do
you're just going to be running baby
you're going to be going so hard you
won't be able to breathe
nobody will be able to stop you because
you're going to believe
that you had your future in your control
you know why because you do and you
deserve it
you work too hard to be taken advantage
of by all these companies
and all this mythology around this
subject of money
you work too hard to be victimized
by bad principles and
bad values it's time
it's time america it's time you took
your life back
that's what this reset is about put you
in a completely different position
that is not your friend so if you're
on a budget and you know your money
tendencies
and you're in training you're not just
trying
so we've got the discipline we're doing
the budget we're saving
we're getting out of debt you know
what's going to happen you're going to
have money
and i'll tell you the next thing that's
going to happen it's going to surprise
you you're
automatically going to become
outrageously generous
you're going to become generous because
you know why people aren't generous
because they're just trying to eat
they're just trying to take care of
their house
when you're all focused on just survival
it's hard to see
other people's needs but when you've got
survival covered
and somebody's sitting there that has a
problem you can help them
it puts you in a completely different
position when you're holding money like
this
instead of this i was in the supermarket
the other day i don't go to the
grocery store much my wife does most of
that for several reasons
um one is i'm just not good at certain
things and lions
is one of them i can can you imagine me
and a lion it just doesn't work you know
and so
but and so for me i see the grocery
store as a pit stop
and a nascar race it's all about
efficiency and effectiveness
so i'm going to dial in go in there
click click click click put the stuff in
the basket
and then you know what you do you know
what i do we walk up we're looking at
the lines
we're going she checking is he checking
who's going the fastest way that guy's
got
9 000 things in that buggy i'm going to
this line right and you're trying to
find a line that you can get through the
most efficiently and the fastest right
well i pick out what looked like
an efficient line until this woman
with her kids running
wild through the grocery store
is holding up everything
now i'm ashamed to admit that i had an
attitude because she was messing up my
pit stop
and i wasn't half watching and then the
corner of my eyes saw it
card was denied
and then i started looking a little
closer those kids that were running wild
weren't
they weren't really dressed very well
she's having a hard day no
she's having a hard year
next card is denied
oh man
i got to tell you i love generous people
you love generous people generous people
make my eyes leak
and i didn't realize it but before my
mind could get my head around i saw what
was happening but i didn't react
and before i could get my head around it
i didn't realize the guy standing in
front of me
i clark kent was standing there i didn't
know it
it turns out it was superman right
that's clark kent
as a hispanic guy with construction
clothes on
muddy boots on and he didn't speak a
lick of english
but you know what we all speak card
denied
we can all look in her eyes and see fear
and pain
can't we and before i in all of my
selfish wonder i'm sorry but it wasn't
me
could move superman's cape come out
and he hands the cashier 200.
and the lady starts crying and tries to
protest and
he's having none of it he said just you
know
no english
probably spoke fluent english
tears running down her face tears
running down my face tears running down
the face of the cashier
love generous people
that change your life won't they i'll
never forget watching that guy do that
i got a friend that's worth about 20
million dollars started with nothing
grew up on a dirt floor
that's what they call dirt poor in
tennessee you ever heard dirt poor
that's what it means it means the floor
of their house was dirt
appalachia
he said dave my whole life i wanted to
save up and take my family
all my kids my grandkids the kids my
kids married
everybody on nice trips once a year i
want to
i want to bless my family i want my
family to all to be together in a
luxurious setting he says one of the
reasons i've worked like an
animal to go from nothing to this net
worth that i have and he said
he's telling me this over coffee he said
i don't there's not many people i can
tell this but you'll appreciate he said
i got to take my whole family
on a mediterranean cruise last year we
were two weeks in the mediterranean with
italy and the you know the mommy coast
or whatever you call that thing and
um man he's he's just telling me all
about the details this luxurious
wonderful trip
and i said well i'm gonna ask
he said what do you mean i said well you
know you're telling me how wonderful
this is what it cost
he said that's about 68 thousand dollars
that's okay he's got 20 million
like it's like most of us buying a
biscuit right
he said i came home and i've been
working with this pastor in the inner
city ministry in a
rough housing area and a pastor called
me up and he said i'm trying to get some
bicycles to give to these kiddos in this
rough area
for christmas would you help out and he
said well i guess i would he goes
how many bikes you need and he said well
i'm just looking for everybody to donate
a few here or there and he said that
wasn't my house to ask how many bikes
you needed
and he told him and he said well i'll do
them all under one condition
that my kids and i can come and help you
hand them out
he said we bought two tractor loads of
bicycles down at toys r them
and two tractor tray loads and we pull
up and these little kids start coming
out of these houses with a big old eyes
mister you got another one and you know
you hand the bicycle off to a little
baby girl little baby boy and they just
look at you
it'll change your life won't it but you
do it for two hours and the handlebars
are spinning around hitting you and
pinching you giving you blood blisters
you get tired of it right
it turns into work in a little while he
said we were there all day handing out
bicycles
kid would come up you got another one mr
yeah we got another he goes
we worked all day long giving out the
two tractor loads of bicycles these kids
coming up
some of them crying we were crying
he said you wanna know how much that
cost i said yeah he said 72 000
both tickets right around 70 grand both
times my family
my kids my grandkids my in-law kids all
involved he said which one you think
they had the most fun at
and we all know the answer bicycles
he said but do the crews too it was
really nice
see you don't have to do one and not the
other to be holy
but generosity is more fun
than anything you'll get to do with
money ever in your life
whether it's superman he may own the
construction company
he may dig ditches i don't know i don't
speak spanish i didn't get to the bottom
of the story
but i do know generosity when i see it i
do know people holding
benjamins with an open hand when i see
it and whether it's a simple 200
grocery bill whether it's paying for the
person in line behind you at the
drive-through
or whether it's two tractor trailer
loads of bicycles
it's just zeros have some fun with this
get control of your money so you get
your life back and you start
understanding what this whole thing
is really about it's not about the
acquisition of stuff
he with the most toys when he dies is
dead
so our first little pig
yolo pig he's got the 700
truck payment in front of a trailer
i've been that pig i've been dumber than
that guy
some of you are as dumb as him right now
it's time to reset or the ish pig
which i think is more of a problem
because they're not as easily
identifiable they
look like they're doing it but they're
really not
they're just sort of doing it it's ish
and the issue's a wish they got a credit
card but they pay it off every month
they get the airline miles because dave
ramsey just doesn't understand
oh [ __ ]
so we want to help all the little pigs
it's ironic that we're putting pigs in
training but it's good
we want to help all the little pigs me
included you included
and so tonight we've been talking about
changes you've got to make small
consistent steps that lead to big
results brick by brick by brick
ramsey plus helps you change your habits
you can start living like no one else so
we're going to do something tonight we
have never done before
in the history of our company with
ramsey plus we're going to offer six
months of it
it includes all the courses like
financial peace university
the six million people have gone through
to learn how to handle their money
legacy journey which is the course you
take after financial peace university
rachel and me teaching a course called
smart money smart kids
on how to teach your kids how to handle
money so when they grow up they leave
your basement
rachel's get just shot a new course off
of her new book know yourself know your
money so if you want the rest of the
story of what she was able to do tonight
it'll be in there courses on budgeting
that rachel and hogan have done
hogan's done stuff on how to get a quick
start virtual groups in there so that
you're not alone
a premium version of every dollar so it
hooks on your app
your spouse has it on their app we're
working our plan together
we have a plan and we work the plan it's
not an accident to win
winning is an intentional act a new baby
steps app is in there
so you can track your progress on the
baby steps and stay right with where you
are
we all need to see progress to know that
we're winning that's why the debt
snowball
works and brand new right now for the
first time tonight
we have the first 90 days that you're in
there we're going to give you
guided action steps day by day
week by week do this then do this
then do this now here's the thing this
ain't our first ride on this cabbage
truck
okay 17 million people listen to my
radio show every week
i've done this for 30 years six million
people have been through financial peace
university
we know how to teach you
how to reset and we've expanded it and
made it even better
with the step-by-step 90-day kickoff
because here's the thing
it's never too early to get a great
start
you never regret getting a great start
on something so we want you to get a
fast start when you go in there
so on top of that when you sign up for
finance for ramsey plus right now for
that six-month deal
with all that stuff in there we're also
gonna throw in rachel's new book
we'll ship it to you called know
yourself know your money and this book
which has sold eight million copies
called the total money makeover
which we'll talk walk you through the
baby steps on steroids and show you
everything
so all of that together is 150 value
it's 85
tonight
so we started the night with the pigs we
have to end with the pigs
the first pig yolo the second pig-ish
pig they escaped
by the hair of their chinny chin chin
and they busted in
to their brother's house homeless
and he said you can stay as long as you
start building with bricks
and when you build with bricks you can
move out and you'll stay gone
so they reset their mindset and they
said we're no longer ish
and we're no longer you only live once
we're gonna live like no one else so
that later we can live like no one else
the bible says no discipline seems
pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
so slowly brick by brick they started to
rebuild their houses
and yolo and ish began to look
and act and talk and walk a lot like
their older brother
the third pig and the rest of the story
that has never been told before tonight
is that they all live in a massive
brick-lined
family compound
and mother pig says i changed my family
tree
i changed my family tree
i've talked to thousands hundreds of
thousands of people
just like you some of them are smarter
than you some of them are dumber than
you some of them have done
ridiculous things that got themselves in
ridiculous messes some of them just
needed to grow some muscle tissue
in their lives they were just flabby
some of them are really messed up i've
walked with people
from the jail from the homeless center
i've walked with single moms i've walked
with millionaires who lost it all
i've walked with everybody of every
color race creed and nationality and
background and culture
and i love every one of them
i love them i love working with you
while you're training
i'm not gonna put up with your excuses
i'm tough
you know why because i'm right
i don't know a lot about a lot of stuff
but this stuff we got dialed in baby
this is what we do if you're looking at
a guy who knows why god put him on the
planet
i know this stuff and this my
me and my team the people that were up
here tonight ramsay plus we
can lead you to where you want to go
if you'll put forth the effort if you'll
put if you'll put your shoulder to the
wheel
we will show you how to do it the
easiest possible way is still not going
to be easy the only thing i can promise
you is it'll be worth it
you can do this you can do this and you
deserve it
you deserve to win you work too hard
you work too hard to be vulnerable when
something like the big bad wolf comes
around
i don't want you to be vulnerable
anymore i want you to have a
brick house i want you to be the third
pig
i want you to be the third pig
say be the third pig
yell it say be the third pig go
one more time
i love you guys good night
all righty then
[Music]
do
[Music]
you